do you think most women are happy being
alone
100 percent
I think married women are the
complaining the most on the internet how
depressive they are and anytime now they
have an opportunity they're going to
complain about being doing the the work
of the house you know like you know it I
think internet now is the place where
people complain most of the time
and it became sometimes boring on Tick
Tock when they start to dance and
sometimes to show
do you know every time it's going to be
the iceberg top what they're going to be
showing on social media is not their
true life or not even one percent of the
true life so you cannot analyze through
social media that's why I'm saying about
the guy asking about oh these pictures
social media it's so silly if you take
Serious okay maybe if someone's hold on
hold on hi I mean you guys need to say
some other Tyrant all right cool so you
believe yeah that most women are happy
being single into into old age no
they became
not wrong that's what I think I have a
couple of friends they become Widow they
start to live live after the six years
you have a couple of friends and so what
no I have amazing examples here like uh
I I don't know much him have like how
many friends do you have you said
they're in their 60s I lived there over
seven different countries I made
friendship or whatever I go but so like
uh
the trains I have like five but
acquaintances I have a plenty and uh
I'll talk to a lot of people five
friends over 60 that are just living
their life happy no I mean like in
general I see when people they move on
their lives okay can I just I'm just
asking like how many single older women
do you know that are genuinely happy
none of them would be happier with a man
that they respect and admire none of
them would be happier in that
relationship with a man they respect and
admire I see more people miserable in
relationships no no no no no I'm saying
if they were with a man none of them
would prefer to be with a man that they
respect and admire I didn't say a man
that they don't respect and don't admire
I said a man that they respect and
admire none of them would pick that over
being alone
I don't know that there's also
perspective okay
sorry guys I think who is single choose
to be single we live in a world with the
deity happy everyone
hold on okay you see these 60 year old
women who are just living their best
life yeah are they still dating yes why
are they still dating because they are
the people the personal knowledge lost
their husbands and start to do dates Now
find the uh boyfriend and enjoy life
again
so happy if they were so happy being
single why are they doing that
I think like is about to do whatever you
feel to do if you want to be single
you'll be single in front of me
you said two different things bro you
said that they're happy being single so
why don't they just continue being happy
and being single but I'm not doing that
this dude I know who got boyfriend I
know who's still single I I just telling
people can leave doesn't matter I think
this thing about dying alone is just
nobody's saying that you keep saying no
one else is saying that I have been
feeling the podcast since I sat here
it's not about feelings
no no no no no no no no no no it go go
by what people say don't try and put
words in people's mouths no one said
that so it doesn't matter how you feel
it's about go on what is said because no
one said that and you keep saying that
over and over and over again and no one
said that to you so I don't know why you
keep saying it maybe I'll pick up the
program he talks a lot about the perfect
relationship and like what the the women
to get the guy and for me sometimes
these things like women supposed to not
be reading how to please a man because
no yeah they don't care because they
only care about what they want yeah
what I came from women learn how to be
the perfect wife they have a
professional life their perfect mother
they are super hot body they go to the
gym every day they want to do everything
to a man and I do not agree with that so
I move abroad I think like who do you
think is easier to please men or women
men are very easy to men for sure men
men are easy to please you but by what
you're saying the women are doing all
these things
to to win the attention and the
affection of men but men are easier to
please who's more who's more inclined to
do self-improvement to attract the
opposite sex
women
they go for plastic surgery absolute
rubbish I think it's women invest more
than men when we talk when is when is
any when have you ever heard the man on
the internet say I want a woman that
makes six figures when have you ever
heard that
doesn't exist
and if a guy was to say he wants a woman
that makes lots of uh not that uh men
want women that are broke but you're not
going to hear a man come out and say I
want a woman a woman that's a
millionaire it doesn't exist even guys
like millionaires don't like require
women to be a millionaire how how do
women self-improve like what what ways
do you see them do it
I think women they they go like if they
want to admit attractive men they're
gonna go to expensive bar they go to the
they're gonna Target the kind of man
they want and they're gonna go to
specific places okay so they need to be
dressing properly they need like to have
the plastic surgery they need to make
the nose smaller and then start can I
can I can I just I want to just point
out something that you said notice how
you said plastic surgery before you said
go to the gym
so what does that say about women's
self-improvement doesn't it seem we take
the easy way out
oh yeah I think we are always trying to
improve women in general more than men
for sure like uh more attractive women
than attractive men for sure
so how so when the majority of women are
overweight so like women have a higher
BMI than men
so it's like again like we start it
starts with looks right so if women are
so about self-improvement even here it's
like 60 70 of women roughly overweight
which is more overweight than the men
so it's like if we're all about the
self-improvement we should probably
start on the treadmill
yeah and I think like when the women are
singles they invest a lot to impress but
of course after they get married
they don't they don't want to try to
impress anymore so they give up on their
height usually he says take me as I am
foreign
who usually says Take Me As I Am men or
women
you know the answer that's why you
didn't answer it you know the answer
it's women that say take me as I am I
look like take me as I am I'm broke take
me as I am I got bad at you take me as I
am I have ridiculous dating requirements
Take Me As I Am bro like bro keep it
real
keep it real
yeah if everybody kept it real the world
would be a better place
so when I asked you who's usually more
inclined to self-improvement is going to
be men
get your money up get in the gym get
social skills
you know just be a better just be
perfect bro
like I mean if you don't agree it's fine
but like I mean you'd have to come with
a logical response like you know what I
mean because you know these things are
real
and we and guys are taught this thing
from early early doors because we are
taught about rejection from early doors
and we are taught that the world doesn't
care from early doors and you know even
even the thing of rejection boom boom
boom most times when God got a guy can't
even complain about oh these women keep
rejecting me to other guys because other
guys will laugh foreign
that's how deep it is now if if you try
to holler at me and I reject you you
could go to your friends oh my God I
tried to I tried to hold that King
riches they rejected me they'll pull put
their hands around yeah he's ugly anyway
that's what happens that's reality
am I lying no there you go
so read and truly like let's just move
back to the super chats because as many
of you know I was just banned on Tick
Tock and we are demonetized on a daily
basis on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible